[MUSIC PLAYING]
PARVIZ DEYHIM: Good
morning everyone.
Thanks for coming
to session DA 202.
Who went to
Chainsmokers last night?
All right, one, two.
All right.
How's your hearing?
Should I speak louder?
All right, so we have
two sessions today.
I know you guys have a
choice of multiple sessions.
So, as a gift, we have
two sessions today.
One by me, I'm Parviz Deyhim.
I'm a big data
specialist at Google.
And with me I have Robin, senior
director of data engineering,
data science from Tapjoy.
Bit of introduction,
what I do at Google.
I'm fortunate enough
to work with a variety
of different customers.
And it's exciting job, I get to
work with so many different use
cases, so many different
customers, and see what they do
and how they do stuff.
And it's not a single day
that I'm not surprised
what customers do and
what customers don't do,
and how impressive the stuff
that they do with the stuff
and with the tools
that we give them.
And Robin is here to tell
you about the journey
that he took from Vertica
on-prem Hadoop on-prem
moving it to BigQuery,
moving the data
and analytics to Hadoop
running on Google Compute
Engine, and a few
other resources
that he's using today.
So all of our customers took the
exciting journey to get there.
And as I was writing
this presentation,
I went back to the journey
that I took back in 2011--
and that's when
I started working
with a variety of different
tools and big data products.
I don't know if
you guys remember
Hadoop 0.2, Spark 0.3--
that's back then when
Spark was running on Mesos,
didn't have its own scheduler.
Remember the days I used
to work with [? Matay ?]
to get stuff troubleshooted.
And then Spark came along,
start taking over Hadoop,
Kafka came along and a few other
different tools came along.
And the reason
they all came along
was to satisfy one goal
that all of our customers
have been asking and
they're asking today which
is reduce time to insight.
Customers want to get to really
fast insight from their data
and they want to get it now.
It's no longer acceptable to
wait for the batch of data
to be processed-- wait for a
day, wait for a week, even.
So that's not
acceptable anymore.
And we're starting to see
the paradigm of people
moving from batch to streaming.
And it's been interesting,
actually, some people are still
[? just doing ?] batch.
Some people are still doing
some part of it doing streaming.
And what I found out from
working with customers
is that simply moving
to streaming analytics
doesn't make your
infrastructure quicker,
doesn't give you ability to get
insight from your data quicker.
What customers have to
do, and what I found out
from working with a variety
of different customers,
is that they have to simplify,
they have to sanitize,
and they have to optimize
their infrastructure.
And that's what I'm going to
talk to you guys about today.
It's a very quick talk
from me, 10 minutes,
and I'll do my pitch.
And Robin is going to come
and talk about their journey.
Hopefully this is clear enough
for you guys to see from here.
But this is
typically-- if I have
to summarize all the
architecture that I
see from my customers,
everyone that I talk to,
this is a general summarization
of what customers do.
And I'm using Google products
here because I love the Google
products, and it's
a Google conference,
you can replace these components
with open source solutions.
So Pub/Sub, you can replace that
with Kafka, or Apache Kafka,
or any other sort
of ingest tool.
Dataflow, Spark, Flink, they're
all open source solutions.
BigQuery, data
warehousing solution,
and you can replace that with
anything else that you like.
But the general theme
is that customers
use some sort of real
time data ingest tool
like Pop/Sub or Kafka.
They use some sort
of distributed system
to take that data and
put it into some sort
of data warehouse, some other
NoSQL databases, or something
else.
What happens is that this is
sort of a good architecture,
but it's semi-optimized.
And I don't know if
you guys-- actually,
it's obvious what's
not optimized here--
you go from streaming,
you're doing streaming now.
But towards the end
they start doing
some sort of
cleaning, aggregation,
joining, and doing
discovery of data.
All this stuff in red
takes time, takes a day.
They wait for it to aggregate,
they wait for it to join data.
Joining data takes a long time.
So from that perspective,
this is not a really streaming
architecture.
This is streaming
at ingest, but still
baffling in a batch paradigm.
So throughout this
talk, I'm just
going to unpack that, talk about
a few things that you guys'
customers should be able to do.
Very high level, but hopefully
it's helpful to you guys.
One of the first things
I want to talk about
is simplify your architecture.
As much as you can, use simple
tools and simple platforms.
It's tempting and
it's very valid
to use Spark, Dataflow,
Apache Beam, Flink,
all the different
distributed systems,
but it's common that I talk
to customers where all they do
is they take data
and do some cleaning.
They do some sanitization.
And if that's all
what you're doing,
you don't need to use
a distributed system.
It's OK to use it, but
with distributed system,
you have to maintain it, you
have to make sure it's updated,
you have to make sure
the bugs are fixed.
You have to deal with
semantics of exactly once
delivery, at least
once delivery,
there's a lot of
complicated stuff
that you have to deal with.
But if all you're
doing is simple tasks,
it would be easy
to use something
like Cloud Functions--
that is, event
driven architecture.
Data comes in, event gets
fired to Cloud Functions.
You do something with it, and
put that data in destination,
and in the sink, or
wherever it needs to go.
It's simple, it's server-less.
You don't have to manage
an infrastructure,
you don't have to
patch anything,
DevOps or anything else.
It's already taken
care of for you.
So very simple, use
simple point of solutions,
something like Cloud
Functions, or other things.
Sanitize your data early.
Generally, or very
common, what I see
is customers do cleaning of data
when data gets to destination.
That's fine, and
it's much better
than many other
architecture I've seen,
but if what you're
doing is cleaning,
try to do cleaning
at ingest time.
Try to do cleaning of data
at the Cloud Functions.
If using Spark
streaming, at Spark,
Flink, Apache Beam
data flow, whatever.
Do that cleaning
early on in a process.
Most customers actually try to
do this, and they're doing it.
So I think this point
should be simple to do.
The other thing is
schema validation.
What customers do is they
put data in destination
and they do discovery
to find data.
But what I like my
customers to do,
is they do schema validation
and schema registration much
earlier in the process.
Because what happens is
that customers put data
in the destination.
In this case, BigQuery actually
does the schema validation
for you.
So you're in a good spot
if you're using BigQuery.
But if your destination
or your sync
does not do schema
validation, make
sure that you do that early
on in the stage of a process.
It helps you with
cleaning of data.
It helps you with the
discovery of data.
It helps you with
the documentation,
what's actually in the data.
Oh, join.
I would say eight out of 10
of slowness of any distributed
data system that I've
worked with with customers
comes from joining data sets.
Joining data sets
that are big, joining
data sets that are
skewed, and joining data
sets that don't need to be
joined at the destination.
So what I found out, and
what some of my customers
do, and I'd love
for you guys to do
is, if you think you
need to join common data
sets at the destination,
at the sink,
do that joining during
the ingest time.
For example, convert
your joints to look-ups.
In this case, I'm using big
table as a NoSQL database
to do a look-up of
data as data comes in
and nest that data before
data gets sent to BigQuery.
So now I don't have to do
joining at the destination
level.
It's not applicable
to every use case.
I'm not saying
you can completely
get rid of join at destination.
But if you can at least 30,
40, 50% of your workloads
using nesting data set
you see an extremely
amount of good optimization
in your queries
and whatever you're
doing at the destination.
So again, the pattern here is to
convert your joins to nesting.
Another thing is
pre-aggregation.
Another thing that
customers do often
is do aggregation at
the destination level.
So they let data go in,
they'd write group bys,
and they'd do some
sort of aggregation.
If you can't, very
similar to nesting
of data, as data comes in
from your ingest point,
try to do pre-aggregation
before data goes in.
I've seen a blog--
one of the customers, what they
were doing is taking the data,
and as data comes in, they
keep a counter in the NoSQL
database, and they
use that counter
to do pre-aggregation of data.
So for example, if they're doing
aggregation on a daily basis--
and let's just say
number of users per day--
instead of waiting for that
data to get to the destination
and write the group by query
on top of that data sets,
what they do is they say
"Here's a simple look-up table
and big table.
This is my day,
and here's a number
of counts for that
element in a given day."
And what they do is they put
that data in a big table.
And interesting
thing is BigQuery
gives the ability to query
big table without moving data.
So now, you have the
ability to join data
outside of your destination
that is already joined.
Now you can write a query
that reads from big table
directly without actually
applying any group by.
It simplifies your architecture,
simplifies your query,
and actually optimize and gives
you much better performance.
By far something that
customers are not doing today
and I'd love to see them do
is create a feedback loop.
And feedback loop
is for you guys
to see what your system is
doing and keep improving it
as you see more workloads.
And this is one of the best
practice of building a system,
like a complex system.
Complex systems always have
sort of feedback loops.
So as you're building
your infrastructure,
as you're building your
analytical infrastructure,
use some sort of audit logs.
For example, BigQuery
gives you an audit log
as an extremely rich set
of data set that tells you
what BigQuery has
done, what queries
has been written, how
much bytes scanned,
what the cost of that query was.
So use that feedback
loop for using the audit
logs to understand what
queries have you run
for the last couple of weeks.
Is it mostly group by?
Is it join?
Do you have a ton
of joins happening?
And run that report
on a weekly basis.
And once you find these
repeated group bys
and joins, take
them apart and see
if you can implement that early
on in the stage of a streaming.
For example, Cloud Functions.
Like I mentioned, bring
nesting into the picture,
bring pre-aggregation at the
ingest time into the picture.
And run this report
every week just
to make sure you're optimizing
your infrastructure.
And hopefully towards the
end this is the picture
you're going to have, where
data comes in from ingest point,
you're doing pre-aggregation,
you're doing joins--
I'm sorry, you're doing
nesting instead of doing join--
at the ingest points.
Clean data will go to
BigQuery or any destination
you guys have.
And you are writing
a federated queries
over big table, where data
is already aggregated.
And now you have this end to end
at a much lower latency, much
reduced latency, and reduce
time to your insight.
That was me.
As I promised, quick,
hopefully that makes sense.
Next, I'm going to bring
Robin to the stage.
Before he speaks, I'm going to
say one fun fact about Robin.
I was having dinner with
Robin, and I found out not only
he's a director of data
engineering, the director
of data science at Tapjoy, he
is a multi-marathon runner,
Boston Marathon runner,
ultramarathon runner.
And I don't know if you guys
know what ultramarathon run is.
That's running two marathons
in the same day, 52 miles.
He's not a normal human being.
So that's Robin on the stage.
ROBIN LI: All right,
thank you everyone,
I'm Robin Li, director of data
engineering and data science
engineering here at Tapjoy.
So jumping quickly
into our agenda,
very quickly we're going
to talk about two pieces.
First one, we're going to
talk about MPP solution,
one of the rock star
product from Google.
And then the second
part, we're going
to talk about our
journey switching
from our on-premises
data center into GCE.
Specifically, we're
going to touch point
on how do we actually run
elastic MapReduce workload
and Spark workload using GCE.
So there are going to be a lot
of materials in my session,
so I put a lot of the details
like configuration logic
details in my slides.
I may not necessarily cover
all of them, especially
on the second part.
Just make sure you
get the slides later
on if you want to refer back to
the logic and configurations.
So all right, let's move on.
All right, so, very quickly who
we are, who is Tapjoy, what do
we do?
So in short, Tapjoy is
advertising network.
We're sitting in between
advertisers and partners.
We have our SDK
integrated pretty much
into all the top apps within
Android and iOS Store.
And also we're buying
our supplies and demand
from open exchanges.
So in another word, we are all
the annoying videos, banners,
and messaging pop-ups you have
when you're using the app.
The chance is, pretty much,
it's actually from us.
But we try to deliver
the right advertisement
to the right people,
at the right moment.
And because we
have our own SDKs,
we have all the user
interaction signals
when you interact with an app,
and when you're interacting
with an advertisement.
So putting all of these
into some perspective,
our daily data addition
is about 25 terabytes
and it is compressed.
If you decompress it, it's
about 100 terabytes per day.
So our team is
very, very vertical.
Starting from the
right-hand side,
we build our own infrastructure,
including provisioning servers,
bring the data in, clean
them up, make sense of them,
training the modules,
and send them out
for real time advertisement
predictions at about 500,000
to 700,000 RPM, with a latency
less than 20 million seconds.
So as you can imagine, our
technical stack is very deep.
And part we're going
to talk about today
is one, MPP, and two, Spark.
This is the whole architecture
of our current data science
stack.
I just want to put
the point which
I can attach today on the map
so you guys have a reference.
OK let's start with BigQuery.
In 2014, we were facing
increasingly challenge
of how do we scale up
our existing MPP system
with very limited resources?
And more ambitiously, how are
we going to do it cheaper?
I mean not only per-query
cheaper but also
as a total cost cheaper.
So those are the configurations.
Very standard ones.
Those are the
functions we supported
before the migration of
data warehousing, ETLs,
and we aggregate them using
highly aggregated data marts
into star schema and the
snowflake schema functions.
And supporting all of
the reporting system,
supporting analytic
ad hoc operations,
and we support all the data
features operations, et cetera.
So as you can as
you can imagine,
those put a lot of
challenges on our small team.
So storage compute
tightly coupled
together on Vertica,
one doesn't really
scale with the other one.
And we also have all of these
technical burdens on DBA admin
tasks and DevOps tasks.
And adding on top
of that, the cost
is another burden factor
including the licensing
cost, support cost, plus the
costs running our hardware
by ourselves.
So that's why one big query
coming into the picture
is quite a revolutionary
solution for us.
And to be honest, all
of these challenge
are not very specific
to Vertica at that time.
It's particular-- I
think it's very, very
common issue that everybody's
facing back to four
or five years ago.
So let's take a look at BigQuery
When you get into BigQuery,
all the storage compute
are virtually unlimited.
If we want to scale
up the issue's
pretty much just
Google's problem now.
And in BigQuery, there there's
no more of this projections,
that projections, BigQuery
doesn't require a user
to put a projections
or annexes on our table
in order to perform.
And no mention there was
no hardware dependencies.
You don't really need to worry
about DevOps or DBAdmin tasks.
And the cost is just
going be cheaper.
I am going to touch
that specific point
in the later slides.
So our migration considerations
again, very standard ones,
right?
We project our cost, we
benchmark our workloads.
The diagram you see
on the right-hand side
was from three, four years
ago, all the top 15 production
queries we were
benchmarking at then.
This is a stacked bar chart.
The right one shows how long
it takes to run it on Vertica.
The blue chart shows how
long it runs in BigQuery.
Just a disclaimer, This is
about two, three years ago.
These days, I'm sure BigQuery
will run much, much faster.
The only thing I
want to highlight
on this particular slide
is remap your data modules,
and how do you translate your
query into BigQuery syntax?
The reason I want to
highlight these two parts
is, back to three
years ago, BigQuery
wasn't supporting the
standard SQL syntax.
And it didn't really support
the partition table, i.e.
The logical partitions.
So that's why we
spend a lot of time--
I'm sure if we want to go
through the same journey again
these days, we don't need to
put the same amount of resources
and time on these two parts.
So jumping straight into
outcomes, scales and cost.
We are able to twice scale
our data storage just
within one year after
we migrated to BigQuery.
And we were able to bring
the cost down to 30%.
And interestingly, that
factor still holds these days.
Putting into some
context the hardware cost
that we pay when we
run on Vertica still
exists, exceed the total amount
that we run our total workload
in BigQuery these days.
And all the technical benefits
we got, such as you've
got these high availability,
automatically available to you,
and all of these disaster
recovery capability.
The last piece
actually came to us
out of a surprise, which
means we're actually
seeing a lot of less data
friction when end user trying
to utilizing our
data and using data
to drive the
day-to-day decisions.
Let me give you some examples.
So we're starting
to see increasingly
number of account managers,
salespeople, product
managers starting to
use BigQuery these days.
I think that's only
because one, using
BigQuery is just as fast
using a Gmail web interface.
You don't really
require the user
to install a SQL
driver or SQL analyzer
by starting to use that.
And secondly, sharing data
in BigQuery is very simple.
All the queries can be saved
down to a link and shared.
And also you can also run that
query set down to a data set
and set share with
your counterparts.
So all of these
combines together, we
see increasingly data adoptions
within our organizations.
So the next few
slides, though, I'm
going to try to attach
some of the good practices
or our practices when it
comes to using BigQuery.
And hopefully,
it'll help you guys.
So first of all,
partitioning tables.
If you are on the Legacy SQL
in BigQuery, very intuitively,
you want to merge the
less frequently used
small partitions
into bigger ones.
And if you are already on this
standard SQL these days, what
we actually recommend
you to do is you actually
don't expose the raw
data to end user,
because that's actually
a white one large piece
of logical partitions.
And instead, you can define the
layer of views for user access
and using something
called authorized views
to give different user different
access to different portions
of your partitions.
All right, moving on.
We absolutely encourage
people to starting
to versioning their schemas
and standardize their schema
controls in our practice.
For example, we
don't allow end user
to change any of the
schema definitions
with incorporation schemas.
And instead, if you
wanted to add a column
or change a column, we ask
them to put in a pull request,
checking all of their
schemas as a JSON file.
And there are going to be
automatic deploying process
to order the table after
the pull request has
been reviewed and approved.
Specifically, we
encourage our users
to put a description field right
over there, in the schema file.
So later on, when those
schema are adopting BigQuery,
you can actually
see the description
on the preview feature.
That's actually a pretty
neat feature in BigQuery.
You can actually preview
the data and preview
all the schema definitions
along with the description field
to further encourage making
sense of data and data
adoptions.
The next one is
about cost control.
I've been asked a
lot of questions.
How do you guys actually do
cost control in BigQuery,
because BigQuery
charge you about amount
of data moved per query.
The way how we do it
is by putting quotas
not onto the main
production scheme projects,
but on different other
projects that different user
groups belong to.
For example, our core production
projects sitting in the middle,
we have different satellite
projects around it.
And each different user group
belongs to the satellite group.
We have quotas set on those
projects, but all of these user
can still access to the
production projects.
And that way, they can
use their own quota
from their own
projects but still have
been able to run queries or
workload against the production
schemas.
The last one right
in BigQuery section
is the HyperLogLog function.
It is a function used for
cardinality estimation
we use a lot.
We are absolutely loving it.
And for example, you can just
estimate your cardinalities
for each segment and
put it into a Scratches.
If you want to estimate
the cardinality
across all of the segments,
you can merge them together.
When it comes to Google's
version HyperLogLog,
they actually improve
it in terms of precision
and proficient and efficiency.
They call it HyperLogLog plus.
Right so I'm going
to take a moment
to pause for a little bit.
Do we have any Google BigQuery
PMs sitting in the audience
today?
No?
All right I'm still going
to ask that question.
How about exposed to HyperLogLog
functions from Google via a API
or a standardized library
so we can actually
produce those sketches
outside of BigQuery?
My use case is I want to
starting to produce cardinality
as soon as users come in
in my streaming process
and I want to dump them
later on into BigQuery.
Right now, I'm not
able to do that.
So that's something I want to
ask Google's PM to think about.
So the next section.
Two years after we
adopting BigQuery ,
our on-premises data center that
we built for Hadoop and Spark
coming into the
end of life cycle.
So basically people
are facing two options.
One is to attack refresh,
refresh all of these hardwares
and continue [INAUDIBLE],,
or you can going back
to your cloud platform.
So we're more leaning
towards the later one.
Although we have a lot of fun
building our on-premises data
center, there is a lot
of technical burdens.
Given the maturity
of the Cloud system,
I think it just makes
more sense for the company
our sizes to lean more towards
from the cost efficiency
point of view.
So this is a brief history how
our data science computational
infrastructure evolution path.
So when I got here
in 2011, we only
have five note of Hadoop
we put it into AWS.
It was insanely expensive.
You cannot believe how expensive
it is back to seven years ago
if you want to run five-node
tiny cluster in a cloud.
So the next year we
decide, OK, so we
want to run our own bare metal.
We use a company
called Softlayer,
later on being acquired by IBM.
And then in 2014,
we decide that's it,
we want to put x million
dollars, buy our own hardware,
and put it into a data center.
We actually put it a few
blocks away from our--
actually the AWS US East 1
data center a few blocks away.
We tunnel them through with
a direction fiber link.
And then we outsource all of
our data center operations
to Equinix.
We use level 3 as the network.
We were hire Metacloud to do
the virtualization layer for us.
We do all of these
outsources, but we still
got all of these
technical burdens,
like turnaround time of the
smart hands in a cage trying
to swap a node, et
cetera, et cetera.
So in 2017 we decided
to try Google Cloud.
And those are the considerations
again, scales and cost
and technicals are very
straightforward and intuitive.
So there is no upfront
capital anymore.
You don't need to worry about
hardware depreciation cost
and the piece that made us
to lean more towards Google
is actually our data strategy.
We have running in AWS for our
service layer for a long time.
But I think its time for us
to look at a different vendor
to provide one single
vendor lock down.
And plus, we have been
running in BigQuery
at that time for over two years.
We think it just
makes sense for us
to put our Hadoop
and Spark technology
closer to our BigQuery piece.
And the last piece
is we were running
a lot of machine-learning
module at that time.
And we think it's
the time for us
to start utilizing
some of the TPU power
that provided by
Google Cloud ML.
All right.
What specifically why do we
run elastic MapReduce and Spark
using GCP, not
other cloud vendors?
There are basically two parts.
First of all, if you want to run
the elastic MapReduce and Spark
cluster, one essential
point is the cloud
should be able to provision
the VMs fast enough
to minimize the overhead of
scale up and scaling down.
Google always has been known as
the new kid around the block.
So a lot of the APIs they can
design from the ground up.
It's actually very
efficient when it
comes to the VM launching time.
The other reason is the pricing.
If you want to run a good,
stable, Spot Fleeting AWS,
you should have at least beat
around 30% on their asking
price.
But if you want to
do the same, preempt
both instances in
Google, they just
give you 80% straight away.
That's something we
consider as pricing
advantages over other piece.
How about this
specific elastic usage?
So this is a CPU utilization
chart I put it out
from about 24 hours a day.
And if we zoom in
you can actually
see between different
times, we're
just utilizing different
levels of CPU usages.
And the framework itself
is about detecting what's
the resources needed in the
queue and trying to scale up
and scaling down accordingly.
So you guys probably want
to argue there are just
a lot of different vendors
on the market trying
to do the same thing, right?
There's Databricks,
there is AWS EMR,
and there is Kubo, all
trying to do the same thing.
Why do we have to try
to do it by ourselves
as an in-house solution?
The reason is we
are looking at some
of the specific features
is not available from one
single vendor.
For example, we
wanted cluster to be
able to run both Hadoop and
Spark within the same cluster.
We wanted to be able to do
with Zun balancing and seeking
the best pricing within
each of the Zun and capacity
within each of the Zun.
And also we want to run
heterogeneous clusters.
Different note sizes,
different note types, and there
are just other benefits, we
try to do some customizations.
All of these functionalities
that we require
didn't really come from one
single vendor at that time.
So that's why we decide
to build it by ourselves.
And more importantly, you
know how hard can it be?
Turns out it's
actually not very hard.
It actually takes our one
developer three months
to put all of these
pieces together.
So technically it's
totally doable.
But you know if you want to
run the actual cloud production
environment, the tuning
and configurations actually
takes longer time.
So first thing we did is
to separate the compute
and storage.
That means our Hadoop and
Spark cluster doesn't really
persist any permanent
data ordinary HDFS files
within the cluster itself.
Instead, we persist
our permanent data
on the cloud storage.
That doesn't really mean
you cannot store any data
on your local hard drive.
You can still store
temporary data and provision
the local hard drive for your
Hadoop and Spark cluster.
The next piece will be the
MapReduce and Spark cluster
themselves doing
all the hard work.
We're using YARN as our
resource manage layer,
and we use Ambari as the open
source cluster management tool.
The last piece in there is
just a general cloud API
that provided Google for
spin up a VM shut down VM.
So the problem is that piece and
this piece, traditionally, they
don't talk to each other.
So all the framework's
trying to resolve
is talking to all of
these different pieces
and making sure they
work in the right order.
So let's look into
different pieces one by one.
I already talked about cloud
storage PC, absolutely need
to separate your storage
and computing in order
for them to scale accordingly.
And there are just two ways to
structure your Hadoop and Spark
cluster.
One way is you can have your
per cluster per job which
means whenever you spin up a
job, you spin up a process,
you can spin up a cluster.
And as soon as the job finishes,
you shut down that cluster.
This is actually a very
clean, easy way of doing this.
But we actually see a lot of
overspending and over-provision
happens around there.
For example, one of
my data scientists
just requires a 100-node
Hadoop cluster living in there
for like 10 hours.
Nobody knows.
So in other words, don't
trust your user, right?
The way how we provision
our cluster is we
have a finite
number of clusters.
And within each cluster, with
structured it into two layers.
One is what we called
Persistent Node, which
is the node runs 2007,
which runs the Master,
to Namenode, Resourcemanagers
and Zookeeper,
et cetera, et cetera, those
controlling functions.
And we also have two to three
what we called Base Slave Node.
The reason we have the Base
Slave Node in there to run 24/7
is basically because a lot of
the small jobs in our system
comes and goes
really frequently.
You absolutely want to avoid
that VM launching overhead.
And plus, certain
may produce jobs
required to persist
a application binary
within a cluster themselves.
So those nodes are for
those purposes as well.
The rest of the layer will
be just the Ephemeral Layer
where we're using
spot or preemptible
instances so they can scale
up and down automatically.
The YARN piece, there's
really just nothing
too much to talk about.
You can use Mesos
if you want to,
doesn't really make a
whole lot of differences.
But the only thing
I want to point out
is this planning
resources section,
when you query that
YARN JMX matrix,
this is the
cluster-wide average.
Remember, I said our cluster
requires heterogeneous clusters
to run different node
sizes, different node
type, different node types,
which means we can support
different size of containers.
So that means when
we run this, we're
going to be a little
bit clever when
it comes to how much resources
is pending in the queue.
Because this is actually close
to average not per application
or process average.
So moving on.
The next two parts
are really simple.
Ambari open source
Cluster Management Layer
defines what components
install on a cluster.
Within each of the components,
what other configurations are.
This is actually optional piece.
I'm not sure if we have any
Hortonworks people sitting
here.
But if your workload is simple,
if your cluster component-wise
is simple, you can
ignore this piece.
But this is a good tool,
open source from Hortonworks.
In our cases, we just grab it
and use it in our framework.
The next one is cloud API.
There's just not really
too much to talk about it.
But one thing I
want to point out
is try to extract your
calls to the VM layer.
Let's say if I want to
support multi-cloud operations
in my clusters--
Google people may
not like this--
but let's say you want to
support both the AWS and Google
within my framework--
when my framework
wants to span up a VM,
the underlying layer
needs to be abstracted
to know how to span
up a VM in Google
as well as how to
open up a VM in AWS.
The next one is
just a quick example
of what they called blueprint
definition from Ambari which
gives you the definitions in
a JSON format for Host Group
components definition,
other configurations,
and hosting classifications.
And at runtime,
Ambari can just grab
all of these configurations
and construct a cluster
by themselves.
When a resource request
coming into the queue,
those are the life cycles.
Very intuitive.
When there is a request,
we check whether there
are resources available.
And then we run a job
after job is done.
We shut down the node.
Very intuitive.
What's the hard part
on this diagram?
The hard part is
actually this piece.
When do you try
to release a node?
That comes to two parts.
One is how do you actively
detect which node is idle?
And the second one is how do
you deal with sudden termination
of your node?
Let's say in the middle of a
job, one of my underlying node
just get kicked out from
the cloud themselves
because of supply constraints
on the preemptible instances.
So I'm going to touch those two
pieces in the later on slides.
This is the framework
general structure.
I'm not going to go into
too much into details,
you can always refer
back to the slides.
The only thing that
I want to call out
is this particular piece.
When you run a heterogeneous
cluster of different node
sizes, different node
types, different node types,
you absolutely want to normalize
each of these node types
and resources into a
single unit so you can
do across the board comparison.
For example, if you have
a X large instances,
and if you have n4
xlarge instances-- when
it comes to computational
resources and job resources,
how do you compare
these two together?
In our cases, we normalize
into one single base
unit, the r4
equivalent 1.5 SCUs,
the n4 equivalent to 1.2 SCUs.
So we actually borrowed this
concept from Databricks.
The way how they use
this normalization
is to charge pricing
for their customer.
What we think is,
that's a cool concept
we can use it to compare
resources requirements as well.
And those are the actual logic
when it comes to the resource
calculations.
Unfortunately, Tapjoy is
not an open source company,
so I'm not actually able to
show all of our actual code here
but I use pseudo-code
to describe the logic.
You also probably notice I
stripped out a price beating
part.
This is solely for AWS.
As for Google, you
don't really need
to do that they just gave you
80% discount straight away.
The only reason we
want to do this in AWS.
It's because we
train our own module
to look at a
histogram of the price
as well as all the
spikes on the pricing
to try to predict all
the pricing at a given
future for a particularly
instant type for a given Zun.
But that case doesn't really
apply to the GCE part.
The next few slides
it's about how
do you tune your cluster
on the cloud environment?
There are a lot
of configurations
and considerations that
we learn from running
our elastic MapReduce
on the cloud.
But I'm not going to go
through into the details,
the only thing I
want to call out
is this specific
piece on the top.
How do we define idle
resources within your cluster?
It's actually working different
ways in Spark and Hadoop.
In Spark, executor
doesn't really
exit until this job finishes.
So it's actually
very clean and neat.
You can shut down a cluster
resources if there is the Spark
or a particular Spark
job is finished.
However, when it
comes to MapReduce,
a release on the computational
resource on Hadoop
doesn't really mean to release
of the entire resources
for that MapReduce job.
For example, if
you have a mapper
produce some intermediate
output and store
on a local hard drive,
although the mapper finishes
and release the
computational resource,
it doesn't release the local
temporary data that generated,
which is going to be utilizing
in the later on stage
after shuffling in
the reducing stages.
So if you chop down that note
at this particular moment,
you reduce or will have to
go asking the mapper again
that mapper is going
to span up once again
to reproduce those data.
So you got to be careful
not only checking
the computational research
released from a MapReduce job
but also check whether
the data are also released
from that particular node.
All right so for the
last few minutes,
I absolutely want
to attach the point,
how to manage instance lifecycle
on a preemptible instances
fleet within GCP.
So this is about
two weeks of data
I took from the end of 2017.
Each of the bars here
shows you how long
each preemptive instances runs
before the cloud kicked them
out.
So we're not trying to
proactively kick them out.
We simply launch the instances,
have them sitting in there
and try to see how long it goes.
The scales are a little
bit difficult to see,
but the right line here
marks about one hour.
And if we zoom in,
we can actually
see the lifecycle of
a preemptible instance
within Google cloud
are very sparse.
So within a framework, not
only just MapReduce or Spark
or whatever the
service layer you'll
run with on a cloud
environment, if you
want to utilize a large amount
of preemptive instances,
like in our case we
run 99% of our workload
on preemptible instances
for Hadoop and Spark,
you've got to have some
fall over strategies
to protect yourself, to
ease the DevOps operations.
Fortunately, YARN
already handles three out
of the four pieces free.
But you still need to do
something for yourself.
If you're on your job pipeline
level, if you want to--
let's say if you're running
in Jenkins and or Airflow,
always have a retry strategy so
that your DevOps people don't
need to go in there
and rerun the job
if they've ever failed because
of the preemptive instance got
take away.
But even if the above is
not very safe as well--
let's say, in our cases,
by the end of the day,
we try to run an end-of-day
batch to refresh our modules
and refresh all the statistics
we used to build up the module.
All of these jobs
runs really long,
about three or four hours.
Inevitably, all of
the retry has a limit.
So the way how we do
this is, first of all,
at the beginning
of this batch, we
washed out all the
preemptible instances.
And then we filled
up the cluster
with non-preemptible ones.
We hold this
cluster size steady.
By the end of the
batch, we washed out
all of the non-preemptible
ones and we
let the cluster do themselves,
sorry do their own things using
preemptible instances.
This is actually a
very clean and neat way
of doing this,
guaranteed to work.
The downside of
this is when you're
used to non-preemptible
instances
you got to pay like eight
times more expensive
than the preemptible ones.
At the beginning of
our adoption into GCP
this is actually the
way in production,
but these days it's not.
These days we do a hack.
If you're interested
how do we do
that for preemptible
instances, feel
free to contact me
because that hack relies
on analyzing Google's
behavior of its own data.
So I don't think I should be
able to disclose on the public.
But ping me if you have
that question in mind
after the work.
I know there's a
lot of, again, I
know there's a lot of
materials I went through.
For the specific logic
and configurations,
refer back to my
slides if you want to.
That marks the end of my session
and now will come Parviz back
so we take questions.
Thank you.
[UPBEAT THEME MUSIC]